just make them on your phone like the
technology to be able to make a movie so
you can just do it
dude I mean the phones that we have now
our dog [ __ ] compared the phones will
have in ten years yeah Soderberg just
shot a whole horror movie on his iPhone
did it really yeah what is it it's
called unsane whoa
yeah yes girls it's trapped in a mental
institution
isn't there a horror movie that's out
right now called hereditary what is that
about is that a good one really good
play the trailer I love trailers
sometimes the trailer is the most
enjoyable part of the movie sometimes I
have to give you too much though oh yeah
they do that with comedies man they give
you too many goddamn punchlines
give me some volume crank it we get in
trouble for this
I don't will you pulled from you turret
trailer we're helping them yeah I mean
if you're long as you guys are like
talking about them we can maybe stop at
37 give me some scary it starts with a
dollhouse that is a scary time for an
architectural design house a model good
enough cause some man walks in it as you
soon
that was cool it made it look like a
real room slums underground the
production companies under strange new
faces here today I know my mom would be
very touched and probably a little
suspicious
Gabriel burns in it my mother was a very
secretive and private woman from the
producer of the wizard show which which
I didn't say heard it was good though
no and what's her name baby she was what
so easy because she made a differently
shark oh no she was a very difficult
woman Damon Wayans maybe it's what what
sometimes I swear I can feel the [ __ ]
is crazy
got a kid with mental problems look what
demons know she looks good private
friends the generations the exercise
take care me you don't think I'm gonna
take care but when you died she's coming
up Crips you with real hard
unspeakable kind this looks good at the
end
Wow
a modern day that's like some guys
cookies this does a very scary
I just don't want to put any more stress
on my family that looks good that looks
scary I can't see it
why can't you see cuz I can't see
anything when do you see things are you
talking about
we just said looking about do you ever
watch stuff yeah go to the movies you do
yeah when do you do that whenever I can
[ __ ] wrong with you you're writing
books and bacon bread take a couple
hours off go to the goddamn movies